that's part of the opening night
performance of step Afrika the first
night of the three-week off-broadway run
the dance troupes triumphant return to
New York as part of a 25th anniversary
tour that continues to spread the long
legacy of stepping across the globe if
you've never seen dance moves like this
before welcome to the stage of step
Afrika the professional dance company
performs stepping an American invention
rooted in African tradition born on
black college campuses a century ago
stepping is an art form first developed
by African American fraternities and
sororities that uses the body as an
instrument see Brian Williams is its
founder first time I saw it was walking
on campus at Howard University
me too homecoming scepter step show all
the Greeks Williams pledge the oldest
one Alpha Phi Alpha fraternity I am a
real man at gamma man when you asked to
speak but then came 1988 and director
Spike Lee's film school days
that was a huge moment because for the
years that have been like the secret
this artform if you weren't around the
college campus you might miss it but
school days kind of brought it out and
from there stepping took off Williams
launched step Afrika in 1994
after hosting a festival celebrating the
election of Nelson Mandela in post
apartheid South Africa oh it was a wild
time I think which is young excited
wanted to do something different wanted
to bring these two cultures together but
it was his visit four years earlier that
truly set the stage I'm there in 1990
studying and working and that's where I
first saw the South African gumboot
dance and it looks so much like stepping
that I had to kind of do a little more
research on it and what did your
research find I found out it was an art
form created by men who worked in the
mines in South Africa and it was a
percussive dance
they used the body as an instrument just
like Stephanie in 25 years
Williams is taken stepping global
touring 49 states in more than 50
countries it's even got its own
interactive exhibit at the National
Museum of African American history and
culture every four minutes a young
person being yes to learn how to step
looks tough Africa and it's resonating
in the last two decades steppin has made
its way into music videos including a
Beyonce routine there's even a movement
to bring the platform to n-c-double-a
teen level competition just about
everyone
ATandT tries to get in on the act
but on this circuit artistic director my
fun okkk fun let me get the middle
manages 15 full-time artist she joins
step Afrika 15 years ago it's the rhythm
within your body it's within your soul
and you're gonna get different sounds in
different tones and different rhythms
from different parts of your bodies
things you wouldn't even you know snaps
and you know making stomps and and clock
yes Oliver natural I'm Miss McCauley
this year's calling the national tour of
drum folk it's the company's second show
to run off-broadway in three years
drum folks the vision of historian dr.
David Pleasant and folklore especi Jones
seen through the lens of director Jakari
Sherman where does stepping come from
what happened when the drum was taken
away drum folk traces the deep-seated
roots of stepping to an event in 1739
called the Stono rebellion about 20 men
from angola rose up near the Stono River
and the colony of South Carolina they
were using drums as they went along and
they gathered gather people by the end
of it was maybe a hundred people right
it lasted just a few days but the
backlash prompted even harsher slave
laws recognizing the power of the drum
in this insurrection the colony enforced
what became known as the Negro Act they
restricted the reading and writing they
restricted gathering they restricted
traveling and that's a good thing but
most importantly at our story they
restricted the use of the drum and the
drum is so tied to culture African
culture also tied to so when that was
taken away the body became the drum for
step Afrika the drum has come full
circle what are you most surprised about
what blew your mind on this journey for
years I wanted to step in the White
House
and I was like we need to be in the East
Wing under those chandeliers and we
didn't make those chandelier shake so
when President Obama was elected I was
like okay I'm gonna have to make a move
it took eight years but in February of
2016
Williams's wish was granted step Afrika
made it to the East Room and the art
form of slaves was performed in the
house that slaves built that was
absolutely incredible you got that on
film oh yeah on the iPhone unless it's a
that but yeah we got to capture what was
the chandelier glycan quakin we made we
made a mistake and you know it did you
know it is touring it starts its tour at
the new Vic theater in it goes till
March 15th but believe it or not the
corona virus might halt part of that
tour internationally so they're waiting
to see how things go
it's just beautiful and unison and in
sound and each body is different it's
just amazing that is you guys you have
to tribal yeah oh yeah mr. Collings I'm
Greek officially but I never got a
chance to step on campus